chinese warplanes take to skies this
just was given nine minutes ago guys
this this was just just went up a few
minutes ago
u.s warships on move before expect a
pelosi visit to taiwan
but they're busting the straight they're
not they're not in the air space you see
buzzing the straight that's been the
chinese thing they're rolling armored
vehicles down the like they
i don't think they're gonna
evacuate or get home people in bathing
suits are just making room for the tanks
look at this that's hilarious latest
footage circulating on chinese social
media wechat shows
what is that armored vehicles on the
move in southern chinese city of
xiaomi i think lots of show like they
had a big parade you know showing their
you know their soldiers and stuff like
that but i mean you never know right i
mean this could be on the onion right
it's like all right chinese citizens
bottom line
are you okay with this move if we're
going to taiwan well we'll know in an
hour
yeah
i'm not joking i mean this is yeah am i
am i okay with it yeah let's ask the
question a different way
um
oh interesting for the website of
government type one also suffered a
brief outage tuesday due to cyber uh
attack or generation i don't think
people would really like spikes no
serious stuff this is so you don't like
this we can do something bigger yeah so
what tyler was gonna say i didn't what
would you say no i just i don't think
people realize how deeply entrenched and
how powerful the chinese are like this
isn't we shouldn't be worried about the
warplanes and the warships and the
armored vehicles no they can take down
whatever they want to take down at a
minute's notice they can literally stop
the economy so can we though they export
i we are so reliant on china they don't
think we have the power of like us no
on you this administration no under
under a person that's willing to put
sanctions and play aggressive yes you
can't a biden cannot play
he cannot play those games
his personality is not that personality
bro
that's different from capabilities of
what the united states
can power does all be the most dominant
center in the league and all of a sudden
get pissed off like shaq and go through
around his weight no
it's a different style right pal is a
different style than chat but that's
different that's my question is
capabilities you know no the pentagon
regardless still has the same exact
capabilities there's then they do under
obama bush
the word capabilities is one thing the
other one is when a nation has been
buying people up for decades
and playing their politics game
better than anybody else and getting so
many the major corporation relying on
them to produce their products their
chips
everything air conditioning so many we
can go there you know the list we don't
need this like a hills medicine yeah so
all of this stuff that they produce yeah
no it's the other way around so
um
respect to her for going i i'm not sure
if the timing is a good timing why
because
this is interpretation say we have
nothing say we're not say we to pick a
country that's got nothing to do with
what's going on right now they're by
themselves pick a country new zealand
okay i'll just say they're just like
sitting in new zealand there's a there's
a podcast in new zealand what was that
was it me oh [ __ ]
okay say we got a podcast in new zealand
and new zealand's like oh [ __ ] what's
going on you know what's going on over
there with the u.s china all this other
stuff here's what they're going to be
saying so let me get this straight
um
first you go after ukraine
and putin told you don't
and you guys try to get nato to get
close so ukraine could be and they're on
my southern border and i told you don't
do it
because you want to have a better
relationship with me
and then you go after
taiwan
what the hell are you guys doing
when when what did you say uh two days
ago with you and uh chris we don't need
to tell the whole story but there was a
one of your girlfriends and he said the
two-week business you know you know what
i'm talking about business it's a
business arrangement right but why was
it a business arrangement it's a revenge
business arrangement yeah we got to get
even right let's not get him i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna get into the story but the
point is we gotta get even right okay
fair
um you don't think china and russia are
saying we gotta get even though
i don't think timing was good
i think timing is a bit off of her if
it's for her legacy whatever she goes
they do whatever they do she'll be able
to write that in her book
um
but but i think while ukraine and russia
is still going on and then you do it
then
i don't know i i just don't know if i'm
sequencing is key i think this is out of
whack sequencing
that's all i'm thinking about well i
think this raises a bigger question do
we support taiwanese independence do we
support taiwan as a sovereign country
what do you mean do we support that for
years we've been saying yes all of a
sudden you want to change it yesterday
and say no that's what i'm saying kirby
came out and said no we don't but but i
believe taiwan is very different than
ukraine ukraine i believe taiwan is a
serious ally i believe their exports are
monumentally important to the u.s
you can make like i'm asking somebody to
make a case you're talking about huh
semi-conductor semiconductors exactly
like eight it's absurd amount of
semiconductors export and imagine they
stop exporting them everything stops
technology ends no more cars no more
computers no more fridges let's go
different direction with that imagine if
china is controlling all of that and we
people have been concerned about 5g i'm
not talking about the conspiracy
theorists talking about health i'm
talking about all of the 5g networks
have been built with
chinese components that people have been
concerned
about embedded technology in those
components that can route data back
and if you think that tick tock is bad
with bite dance and things going on
there and joe rogan said yeah the fine
print just says all your data and all
your keystroking is going to china so if
you think that's bad and 5g is bad
imagine if they control
80 of the world's semi-conductor
production you don't think infiltration
is easy and you don't think
it's it's a whole different level of
espionage whole different level so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]